una promesa colectiva de ayuda
humanitaria fue el acuerdo al que se
llegó en la reunión virtual del grupo de
los 20 que incluye a países
industrializados y emergentes aunque al
encuentro virtual no asistieron ni china
ni rusia fue considerado como un éxito
por el primer ministro italiano y
presidente del g20 y mario drive al
haberse acordado un monto de mil
millones de euros
hay una gran voluntad de actuar adalid y
se compartió la visión sobre la
necesidad de abordar esta emergencia
humanitaria su la necesidad de afrontar
cuestiones humanitaria
los países también se unieron para hacer
un llamado a los talibanes para
garantizar la seguridad y la entrada de
todo el personal humanitario a pesar del
acuerdo en la reunión se anotó que no se
reconocerá al gobierno talibán por la
falta de inclusión de su gobierno a
otras fuerzas políticas y su continua
exclusión hacia las mujeres afganas se
reiteró que los talibanes serán juzgados
por hechos no por sus palabras
todos hemos expresado hoy que en lo que
nosotros respecta como he dicho en
muchos otros también durante nuestra
evaluación de hoy
el gobierno talibán no es inclusivo por
lo tanto la cuestión del reconocimiento
de los talibanes no está en la agenda
antes de la toma del poder por parte de
los talibanes afganistán dependía de la
ayuda internacional que representaba un
75 por ciento del gasto estatal ingresos
que han sido congelados desde el
establecimiento del nuevo gobierno y que
dificultan aún más la grave situación
económica del país